colmar entre 10 à 13 mille camions
empruntent chaque jour sa taxe qui
traverse l'alsace parmi eux 2000 venus
le plus souvent d'allemagne et des pays
de l'est
en cause la taxe poids lourds instauré
en 2005 de l'autre côté du rhin ces
camions traversent donc quotidiennement
la frontière pour bénéficier de la
gratuité des routes alsaciennes un
trafic trop loin pour le département
l'accent alsacien est aujourd'hui
saturée de strasbourg à mulhouse
c'est une file sans discontinuer de
poids lourds sur la voie de droite qui
occasionne tous les jours mais tous les
jours évidemment des bouchons mais
surtout aussi des accidents pour
rétablir les équilibres de chaque côté
de la frontière brigitte klinkert
réclame à la ministre des transports
la mise en place d'une redevance hors de
question pour les transporteurs routiers
des taxes il en a largement assez et
elles sont assez élevés en question
première avant d'ouvrir toute discussion
on voudrait déjà qu'on nous explique où
va l'argent de ces taxes mais selon les
collectivités territoriales il y a
urgence car le report du trafic routier
risque de s'aggraver
le 1er janvier prochain la taxe
allemande sur les poids lourds s'étendra
à tous les véhicules